con un poco más de 100 días como Primer
Ministro Richie suna que está tratando
de reorganizar su gobierno su gabinete
para navegar en la crisis del costo de
vida que lo tiene a él personalmente en
jaque pero a todo su gobierno por las
crecientes jornadas de huelga de
diferentes sectores desde la educación
hasta el transporte que están exigiendo
mejores condiciones de vida segunda un
in Street los cambios hechos hoy buscan
que el Primer Ministro pueda cumplir con
esas cinco propuestas y Esas cinco
prioridades que se ha fijado entre ellas
reducir a la mitad la inflación que ya
supera el 10% hacer crecer la economía
reducir la deuda pública reducir las
listas de espera del sistema Público de
salud en elches que justo esta semana
está en huelga y finalmente de tener los
barcos con inmigrantes ilegales que
llegan a través del Canal de la Mancha
por ello Es una dividió en dos el
Ministerio encargado de comer serán dos
carteras independientes ahora que se
encargarán una de fomentar eso la el
crecimiento de la economía aumentar los
puestos de trabajo en el país y la otra
se enfocará en la ciencia y en la
tecnología pero es una cadena más creó
el departamento de seguridad energética
y netsero que debe asegurar el
suministro de Electricidad de energía
para el Reino Unido en el futuro y lo
que dice el gobierno es que también
servirá para que se reduzcan los precios
en la energía que están disparando esa
inflación finalmente nombró al nuevo
jefe del partido conservador se trata de
Greg Hans quien era ministro del
gabinete y reemplaza a nadinesia Huawei
en este cargo quien tuvo que renunciar
hace un par de semanas por escándalos
con sus impuestos